donc nous nous trouvons ici dans le
canton de guebwiller un canton qui est
composé de 18 communes qui a annexé
l'ancien canton de soultz à celui de
guebwiller où je vous propose
aujourd'hui un petit focus sur la
brigade verte de sousse parce que c'est
une une vraie particularité de notre
département qui travaillent tant sur
l'environnemental
comme je le disais tout à l'heure mais
également dans l'urbain puisque par
exemple pour la surveillance des marchés
de noël en période de fin d'année permet
d'ouvrir ce marché de noël au public en
permettant une sécurité optimale donc le
florival a également une zone
industrielle en plein essor sur les
trois communes design guebwiller soultz
avec une pépinière d'entreprises qui
accueille les commerçants les artisans
je vous encourage à y venir que nous
sommes ici devant les actes des
papillons blancs de soultz où une
centaine de personnes adultes
handicapées travaillent tous les jours
donc c'est pour vous montrer un axe fort
qui est qui est ici mais qui existe sur
l'ensemble du département
pas forcément par le biais des papillons
blancs mais d'autres associations
portent cette très un réinvestissement
des personnes handicapées sur différents
types de handicap au sein du département
pour la commission de l'autonomie et de
la solidarité je m'occupe également des
ehpad puisque nous avons trois ehpad sur
le territoire
soultz nous en avons 1 guebwiller soultz
et un lead the nine alors nous sommes
également sur un carrefour ici très
important dans le domaine du bilinguisme
puisque ça fait de très nombreuses
années depuis plus de vingt ans que nous
sommes que le canton de sousse et de
guebwiller avec the nine et d'autres
communes voisines bull en particulier
peut effectivement s'inscrire le
bilinguisme et de ce partenariat est là
depuis très longtemps avec grâce à
l'obtention le lycée deck de l'abibac
puisque l'on peut évidemment terminer
son cursus chez nous sur le même canton
donc on commence à la maternelle en
terminale au lycée et c'est très bien
pour nous nos jeunes qui peuvent après
promouvoir celui là guise mais surtout
rentrer dans la vie active
en ayant deux armes la technicité et la
langue